hello and welcome to this video playing
boom ah I only recently lost against him
was set on a livestream alien don't
quite remember so no recollection of
that game what happened so we got this
modern way of playing the bank oh how
interesting buddy 92 so it tries to
establish this night b5 this is control
hmm quite interesting approach there
so what to do here one thing though is
this takes ages and what is doing it's
slow its ambitious but also quite slow
so what to do here try to challenge it
with 97
ok
it looks like boo why can I look just
take this
look very well played from White's point
of view just giving me the poor cannot
cannot be the right solution okay you
know I can go tonight if five here maybe
on let's do this be more a little bit
more active him yeah okay that's a it's
a good reply
that's a good reply I still have to take
care of them of the seven poem mm okay
now if I probably wasn't I'm
unsuccessful idea
looks very wish I here now I've got to
be file and can you invade and I'm not
getting made it here which is probably
one of those famous last words
statements but I really don't see how
yeah okay how is like that yeah there
would be like that but I don't think it
should happen
hmm i use a ticking you seven still
the most worrisome thing is the clock
actually time warning that's got to be
one
I still has rookie one down what's that
hang my c3 bishop very strange but okay
he probably has decided that the time
will be winning on time will be the
approach and probably with justification
god damn it didn't have a bad position
here at all especially this F for
business I cannot believe in at all
check check
got six seconds and it probably has some
shake made check check check
Jeff Jeff black forfeits on time yeah so
somehow way where did I actually burn
all that time I mean yeah I bought some
time in the opening when then he
blundered that porn and here I'm just
comfortable of course 95 was a bit too
much sophisticated when this is just
good for black quite clearly f6 Ruby 85
and now I just have to tear this apart
but i'm down a minute hmm yeah of course
the simplest thing to do is just to take
the poor but I didn't want to do that I
wanted to keep the structure and tank
today that's just it's just a minus
Warner but I wanted to enter here
awesome but ok this is this is a good
move f5 21 it still looks terrible for
white but I didn't find the right plan
here absolutely not I mean I was
thinking the week back Ryan k I mean
this is a very strong piece which she is
but she just laude easily the engine
wants to do this and gives black a clear
advantage why can have it he cannot take
because this is immediately winning okay
and this is strong I mean if he cannot
take what about this this movie okay
then he can take and yes this idea so
this is a draw her repetition yeah I
didn't find a totally clean plan here so
clean yeah i blundered see three year i
blundered see three in one move and he
didn't take it and instead Bishop Quincy
four wins for black takes bishop deform
it's just a matter of being precise
against this is typical okay let's wind
your counter play but you have to make
precise moves and I mean okay I blunden
see three years it's just just terrible
it didn't he didn't see it and now
Bishop before wins on the spot I didn't
see how to win after this I this is made
it's made oh my god this is the problem
uh-huh I saw this here with bishop at
all it's not rookie born and doing what
then and then this is of course
brilliant because of who cares no
squares yeah it has no squares a1 b1 if
you go to see one I can just grab here
because of the week background okay that
would have put if one immediately and
have one minute left still and now
things get extremely difficult engine
still gives black a win but ok here you
have two in 12 seconds yeah good I just
take like 20 seconds and so on it's like
yes it's hard to slow leg yeah it's
funny I mean it doesn't really matter
but the position still wins for black f
three wins check da King g5 is still a
draw which I think it's pretty
remarkable the King e5 is a draw I mean
it's irrelevant yeah I do it on time
anyway but i just find it remarkable
that this should be a draw yeah maybe I
yes to check and I mean I've got some
some things going in myself if he just
that I'm blacks winning check check
check check
for example something check check check
no check yeah I final position is this
business better for black again but ok
he wins on time that you don't look
anymore if you know your window in time
yeah pretty pretty bad it's not a game i
should ever lose ok anyway thanks for
watching